[Music]
Thor son of Odin god of thunder and
protector of mankind struggled mightily
against his greatest challenge yet
opening a bag of food it it all started
when Thor along with his fleet footed
human servant the olivey and Loki the
trickster God set out on a journey to
Jotunheim land of the Giants along the
way they'd met a giant named screamer
who offered to accompany them and even
carry their provisions in his bag but
when they made camp scream air dozed off
and Thor couldn't untie the sack
frustrated and hungry Thor tried to wake
the Giant three times by striking his
head with his hammer Mjolnir as hard as
he could
but each time screamer thought it was
only a falling acorn and went back to
sleep the next morning scream ear
departed and eventually the travelers
reached a massive fortress called
boot guard
inside the long haul they met the king
of Giants would guard Loki who greeted
his guests with a challenge each of them
was to prove they were the best at some
particular skill
Loki went first declaring himself the
world's fastest eater to test him the
King summoned his servant
Loki and the two were placed at either
end of a long trough stuffed with food
Loki ate his way inward with blinding
speed but when the contestants met in
the center Loki saw that his adversary
had not only eaten just as much food but
also the bones and even the trough
itself
next was thei olivey who could outrun
anything in the wild the King summoned
an ethereal looking giant named huger
who outraced theology easily but the boy
would not give up and demanded a rematch
this time Yaffe finished close behind
and the king admitted he'd never seen a
human run so fast galva tried a third
time running like his life depended on
it
but huger was even faster than before
finally it was Thor's turn the King
offered him a drinking horn saying all
his men could drain it in two gulps Thor
raised it to his lips and drank the
surprisingly cold and salty Mead in the
longest gulp he could muster than a
second then a third but the level of the
mead in the horn was only slightly
lowered to test
Thor's renowned strength the King
offered a seemingly easy challenge lifts
his pet cat off the ground but this cat
was as tall as the war every time he
tried to lift it it arched its back and
straining with all his godly might he
only managed to lift one paw
enraged Thor demanded to wrestle any of
the giants the King summoned the Giants
old nursemaid le though the woman looked
frail Thor couldn't overpower her and
grew weaker the longer he struggled
until he was brought to one knee the
three companions prepared to leave
disappointed and humbled but as the King
escorted them out he revealed that
nothing in the castle had been what it
seemed
Loki lost the eating contest because his
opponent Loki was a wild fire itself
devouring everything in its path CLV
couldn't outrun huger because huger was
the embodiment of thought always faster
than action and even Thor couldn't
defeat Elie or old age which weakens
everyone eventually as for the other
challenges they had also been illusions
the drinking horn was filled with the
ocean and Thor had drained enough to
cause the tides the cat was the serpent
that encircles the world and Thor's
efforts shifted the earth and screamer
had been food guard Loki in disguise
deflecting Thor's hammer blows to form
valleys in the surrounding mountains
the giant congratulated them on their
prowess which so frightened him he would
never allow them in his land again Thor
and his companions failed the challenges
presented to them but in trying to
achieve the impossible
they'd pushed themselves harder than
ever before and changed the world in
ways and no one had expected if you're
interested in journeying deeper into the
world of Norse gods and goddesses we
highly recommend Neil Gaiman's Norse
mythology it's full of so many
incredible stories and you can download
an audio version of the book for free at
audible.com slash ted-ed
you